everybody is Jessie today we are going
to work on material design style cars so
I have the documentation from Google for
material design here and it's open to
the cards page so if you don't know
about material design or you haven't
read about cars in particular I
recommend you know taking a look it's
material I oh that's the site so I'm not
going to go in-depth into a lot of
things about why why we use cars hey
guys
so people were saying hi in the
livestream thanks thanks for watching
before I start I wanna go over a couple
of things at the end of the lashing
yesterday I had somebody asked about
tips like like money give you money I
think I did ask for tips but I meant
advice so I'm not actually asking for
money I just advise so I really
appreciate the generosity of people
wanting to to give tips but for now
advice is fine
hey I'm doing alright thanks for asking
I also want to thank you guys I had I
did get a lot of good advice so I was
awesome in particular I want to thank
for people who either sent me some
really good links or even went farther
and you just taught me how to do
something since yesterday's livestream
so sorry if I mispronounced any of your
names but I want to thank Bill Dyer a
programmer from Texas Tech Allen nice
Oscar ideas and Martin mestrovic so they
all provided a lot of good help so thank
you I appreciate that a lot and I've
checked out all the links there anything
you guys sent me so I may need to learn
a little bit more
before I implement it but they're all
really cool stuff and I definitely will
learn more about it also between
yesterday's video and the day before
we've had over 8,000 views so it's
awesome it's like it's just crazy to
think about that many people want to
watch this video also I've put some
links in the description so if you want
the link to the source code that we're
working on it's in the description
it's a github repo feel free to you know
clone that repo you could submit a pull
request you know whatever you want the
link to the github pages site where you
can actually see what I'm working on
see that the site is in there and then a
bunch of the links link to my youtube
channel and to some of the other things
that I'm using my code editor the
framework I'm using so somebody asked
again for tips now I don't want any tips
right now I really appreciate that but I
said this yesterday at the end of the
video so if you missed it I'm actually
doing these live streams from from work
so I'm getting paid right now doing work
my boss is awesome and recognizes the
value and this sort of thing and so he's
letting me do this so I don't I don't
really feel comfortable getting tips
while I'm doing this maybe if I start
doing more videos and taking some of my
time at home then I'll want tips
probably my wife will definitely want me
to get tips at that point cuz you have
to watch the kids while I do these
videos and then I guess I could take
euros somebody asks about euros i I
don't know I guess I converted but right
now I'm not I'm not doing tips I want to
be your friend you guys are great in the
live stream right now I'm going to stop
watching the live stream for a little
bit so I can get started on this in
terms of a friend is actually I'm
working on getting an internship program
started where I'm at so I'm in the
marketing department in France
in university I do also do work on the
side I kind of have a company Jesse
while additional working that I haven't
really been doing any advertising for
for a while but I do some work on the
side through them so I guess if
anybody's really interested in doing
some work with me or let me know in the
comments or you know send me a direct
message on Twitter or something okay so
like I said we're going to work on
material design cards just basic
overview in case you're not familiar
with cards they have a certain box
shadow so it looks like they're lifted
off the page and they're container for
content and they help to separate one
piece of content from another if you've
ever used any google apps on Android
then you've seen cards and they're not
just from google apps a lot of different
sites are adopting this a lot of apps on
Android even though it's not made by
Google adopt this and then a lot of
websites too I use the materialised
framework and that it's basically like
bootstrap or foundation except it uses
material design principles all right we
get greens for the Philippines hey
that's awesome your Western from the
Philippines what time is it there me me
show you an exam okay so instead of me
talking about a card not showing you
this is a card this is Google's first
example of a card so if you weren't sure
what I was talking about maybe you've
seen this right all right so enough
about that let me show you what we're
going to be working on so this is what I
need to turn into a card this is the old
site that I'm working off of it's semi
finished and we're turning it into a
different site so in the context of this
word we're going to go over some basics
of material design cars so this is an
example of a card we already did
this is just a full image when you click
it it actually allows you to put in some
more info so that's a decent example of
a card
the first card we're going to do I'm
going to try to get through as many
types of cards as I can and this 206 am
and the Philippines awesome wow thanks
for watching so late I'm gonna try to
get through as many different types of
cards as I can just to show you kind of
how I do cards and all my cards are
really based off of what the
materialized framework provides at first
and then I just modify it to meet my
needs okay so the first thing we're
going to do this section here has logos
you can see some of them are on a white
background so we're just on this cream
color background they're not really
uniform in size so it kind of mixed up
not really a clean look it's not the
look we're going for so the plan is take
each one of these put them in a square
card with a white background so you know
some of these already have the white
backgrounds so we're just going to make
them all have white so that they're
uniform and they're going to have the
same type of shadow like these ones have
when you hover over them they're going
to pop out a little bit that's kind of a
visual cue that hey this is clickable
also they'll have the little change in
the cursor and we're just going to put
them I don't know maybe four across
there might be an odd one out there
we'll see and they're all going to link
to these different websites alright so
let's get started build one of these
cards
let me move this off the screen make
some room
let's see I'll move this off for now so
I'm sure you guys all do this too but I
rarely ever read code from scratch
anymore right you just always borrow
stuff from your old work or from from
other people's stuff so the first thing
I'm going to do is find that section
where we had these cards on the home
that this is the home on the wrong page
so I to the index page since yesterday I
did do some stuff I guess I should
update you see it's not a surprise I
didn't I made
pages for all the different pages in the
site they're basically just copies with
not a lot of stuff in them I remove the
parallax effect from the header I had a
meeting today with some of the people
that I'm building the site for and it
went really well I got a lot of good
information but one of the things that
they did not want was the parallax
effect so basically the parallax effect
made it seem like this was in the
background and it was being covered over
by the rest of the site so they said
this is like a religious institution
this this monstrance is very sacred for
Catholics so they didn't want that
appearance that it was being covered
over but we did incorporate parallax
down below so they had this this cross
this is called a San Damiano cross or
crucifix they had this actually over top
of these images but I thought it was
cluttered so he moved it here I don't
remember if I have this ministry
yesterday's video I moved it here and
had a parallax effect if it's a nice
kind of like reveal effect so that's
that's a lot of wood what I did a lot of
kind of minor things and time spent in
meetings so not not a whole lot of
changes so let me regards from Everest
all right a high from the Caribbean
awesome
how's the weather in the Caribbean I bet
it's it's nice it's really rainy and
kind of a little bit cold here maybe 60
degrees and and rain all day but I'm I'm
in Ohio so I'm I'm actually really close
to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania if anybody
knows where that that's at but I'm in a
little a little city and that on the
eastern side of Ohio all right let me
find this but I was trying to do a
couple minutes ago yes here we go okay
so we have these cars I'm just going to
copy this because the card we're going
to make is going to be similar so let's
go ahead and just copy this whole sex
yeah let's copy this whole thing I want
to see where this actually ends okay
coffee in a section and now let's go
over to the about page so we did have
this page was called our mission we're
changing changing it to the about page
because it not only has information
about the mission but it also has some
pictures of the people a few the three
of the people in charge and it has those
different organizations that are
collaborators that I just showed you a
minute ago so discuss it at the meeting
this morning and we thought well maybe
about would be a better term for that
since the page does a lot more than just
say the mission and we already have the
mission statement on the home page
anyway so let's find the about page and
let's go we I have some sections already
here that I just copied over so let's
see this is a white background section
this will work and we'll just copy in
what we had here and let me show you
some of the markup so you can see it so
it might be a little weird because I've
added things in so let's cut it down
here I'd what I don't want is this card
reveal so let's let's get rid of some
stuff first just to simplify things and
I don't need this class activator or
this class if you're interested in any
of the stuff that I've done so far if
you look at the commit history and the
repo you'll be able to see everything
that gets done between videos so you
won't miss anything I try to be as
descriptive as I can in my commits hey
we got somebody from Pittsburgh alright
um I'm actually grew up in weirdin I
don't know if you know where that is
the m harmon from pittsburgh so it's
it's actually
the city in West Virginia that's really
north that borders Pennsylvania and Ohio
so I'm about a half hour drive from
Pittsburgh I can actually get to the the
west side of Pittsburgh in about 20-25
minutes so awesome it's so cool of
people from so many different places so
that's that's awesome to see I actually
I know I'm missing a lot of stuff I'm
showing the live chat I do go back
afterwards and I read everything in the
live chat so I will see what you said I
might not see it until later if you
really if you have a question they'll
put it in the comments so that I can
reply to it later on if I don't see it
in the live chat okay so basically I
just removed that little part that was
the the part that got revealed
I'll bring it back in to show you so I
had this this reveal I removed that part
because we're not going to use it for
this next set of cards I'll clean it up
a little bit we still want it to be huh
verbal we're still giving this card the
style of cursor:pointer normally you
know you don't really want to put style
tags right in here in this case it's
just easier to to show you what to do
also eventually all this I'm going to
convert it to react components and I am
not really against putting style tags
directly into react components I'll
probably do a better way than that
though but at first this will make it
easier to transition over okay so the
only other thing we have going on here
is we we have this in a row we have in
columns that's just emits here the
column classes for materialise all we're
really worried about here let me
separate it out so we can see I'll put
some spaces in on the actual part that's
the card it's just this stuff here so we
just have two divs and a span in there
for for a title we're actually going to
take this up because we don't even want
to title this is just a straight image
card that we're going to do and
this is such a basic example it's
probably in the materialize
documentation as well and you can just
copy and paste man the only other weird
thing we have going on is we're using
source set to do some responsive images
I went over this in a previous video
that I did on my channel so if you can
check that out on more depth I think I'm
going to do maybe a pre-recorded video
on this at some point so you don't have
to sift through a whole half-hour live
stream to find what I went over this but
basically all we're doing here is just
putting in a different image depending
on screen width and resolution but in
this case let's switch out I did copy
over some of those logos let's check out
the our image folder and let's take I'm
going to take a little bit as a short
name alright OS V logo so I'm going to
switch this up to was that would your OS
B logo dot peel and at this point none
of these are really optimized they
haven't been compressed or anything
we're just kind of seeing how it how it
all goes let me go to that page so we
can see that's the about page now I'll
bring it over on the other screen so
everybody can see it okay somebody's
asking about react I know I've been
talking about react every video I was
just thinking about that earlier we are
definitely going to do react but it's
probably going to be next week there's a
possibility if I can't get if I don't
think I can get it ready by launch which
needs to be some point next week there
may be some delay at the printer for
some other marketing for this site so we
may get an extension on the date when
this has to go live but I'm assuming it
has to be live by the 13th of this month
if I can't get it converted over to
react in that amount of time I'm just
going to put up like the static site
that's why we're doing this static site
first if that's the case then it's
possible I won't get to react till the
week after that but I definitely will
I'm looking forward to it as well I
haven't worked with it a couple of weeks
in our I really miss it I don't know if
anybody has worked with react but it's
it's for me at least
it was kind of hard to wrap my mind
around at first but then once I really
got into it I it was cool I liked it it
was fun to work with and I kind of like
don't want to go back to anything else
after that but you got to use sometimes
it's it's overkill to use your egg
sometimes when you don't have to
Oh's and bob way awesome I've got a beer
some from Zimbabwe okay so you can see
basically what happened this is the card
and we we don't have that that I'm I
forgot to put it on this screen sorry
guys
okay so now you can see what happened we
put that logo in there we I'm clicking
it right now and that effects not
happening because we took all that up
the only thing we want to add though is
we want to add a link so let's pop in
and a tag and so this is I don't prepare
this stuff ahead of time we're just
doing it on the go so just just so you
know I'm trying things out sometimes
they don't always work so I don't
remember exactly how I usually do this
with the 8x so let's just put should I
put it here or should I make the image I
think the best thing is going to be to
wrap this image in the a tag yeah I
think that's how I usually do it for now
I don't remember what this the dress is
for this site so I'm just going to put a
hash in there as a placeholder whenever
you're doing a link always put the title
in because for like screen readers for
people you know vision impairment and
things you want that title in also
somebody that covers over the link it'll
pop up so always keep that in mind that
people have different needs for when
they're viewing the website so it's just
it only takes an extra second but it
could really mean a lot to somebody's
trying to view your site
also I like to use target --blank
if somebody's leaving the site I don't
always use this sometimes it can be
annoying to people it just depends on
the context but in this case well sorry
about that I just scrolled over I hope
nobody's motion sick because I'm kind of
moving windows around a lot I know I get
motion sick really easily so especially
like all the new virtual reality stuff I
just can't I can't handle most of it so
I apologize if all my moving around at
least Windows is making anybody say okay
so I just saved that it Auto refreshes
i'm using gulp to live reload this okay
so we can see as I hover over that it's
going to be really tiny on your screen
but maybe you can make out down in the
bottom left corner it has it's showing
me that there's a URL when I hover over
this so that's the link so this entire
cart now is a link it has this cool
hover effect it also has a did we put a
click effect now we didn't with
materialize there's the option to have
like some click effects and when you
click on something you get like some
waves see if it's doing it here there we
go oh sorry it's hard to see there I
don't know if you can see I'm doing one
more time it has like this wave that's
just emanating from the point where you
you click so why - did somebody ask why
- divs for this card why not add class
card image within the first div okay so
part of the reason why I use this
structure well really the entire reason
why you should structure is since I'm
using the framework materialize the
structure that that they that they
recommend in their documentation so in
their documentation you do have it if I
were making this card myself you're
right it would be so much more simple to
just do one div there have been there
are some occasions when I do
the cards I make them myself usually
when I want to make sure that cards are
all exactly the same height I use it's
easier for me to do that if I have just
the card be one div so I have done that
on occasion but in this case this is
just the markup that is required for the
framework but in general it is I like to
use less markup if possible we had
somebody says hi from Iraq so awesome
that's just I can't believe we are
recovering like all parts of the world
here so that's great also why do you tab
over the image I want to keep the a and
image on the same tab level yeah that's
a good point the only reason I did it
like this is because this image is sorry
I let me read that question out loud
somebody asks why did I I separate this
a element and the image of a why not
just leave it on one line if they were
smaller I would definitely leave it on
one line but since I have so much here
and I already can't even see the end of
it I just I put them out on different
lines so that I can because usually when
I'm editing it looks more like this so I
can see the CSS or the JavaScript and
the HTML at the same time so if it's
going to be really long I'd rather see
it but yeah in general you can review
can just put the image tag in the a tag
on the same line that comes from style
it depends on what you're doing if you
work somewhere where there's like a you
know style for coding like that's
strictly enforced you got to go with
that I don't have that where I'm at at
least not yet I'd like to develop it for
when we start getting you know some
interns or student workers or things but
for now I can kind of do what I want so
I try to be as consistent as I can be
but occasionally I'm not sometimes
you're just in a hurry and you forget
how to do things all right so the only
other thing that I'd want to do with
this car
it is it I definitely don't want it this
bag I shrink it down I'm going to try to
fit maybe four cards on a line but I
want to jump over to something a little
bit more complex this is a really simple
example and if you didn't follow it all
just check out the the source code on
github I'm going to commit all the stuff
from from this live stream as quick as I
can
after this live stream and then also
I'll I'll be working on all the things
I'm saying that I'm going to do today so
hopefully it'll be all be done by the
end of the day today we don't have a lot
of time left so let's try to get started
on this other card as soon as possible
I'm going to flip over I use Trello for
my kind of personal project management
here so we wanted to make cards or
collaborators that's just what we did oh
I almost forgot I need your help we need
based on feedback from the meeting this
morning I did a little demo we need a
different font for the headers so real
quick I want to show you this is the
font for the headers that I'm using now
it's just it's just Roboto so we want a
different font I'll show you what the
font is used on the old site this is the
font that's used
it's a EB Garamond so I have two fonts
that I'm thinking about using a switch
so this is the EB Garamond this is
what's being used right now and this is
a font I found what is the code sins old
okay I kind of really like this bottom
font the thin version of it really
struck me that I liked it and I thought
it might work for this site but I know I
already know this one would work because
this one was already chosen by the
people who are in charge of this
department that I'm doing the site for
hey but if I can find a font that's even
better I can show them and you know
maybe they'll prefer that so I mean I
already told you my preference let me
know because it's not it's not always
about what I think looks good I love to
get second opinion
so let me know in the comments if you
can which font you prefer the one on the
top is EB Garamond the one on the bottom
is sins or you can find those both on
Google Fonts if you want to take a look
at them in more depth or if you have
another font that looks similar to these
fonts that you think would be even
better let me know at this point I can I
can hold off a little while longer
before changing the font on these
headers so I'm open to suggestions okay
we've got three minutes let's let's get
something done in three minutes okay so
the next thing that we're going to do is
with cards for resources okay let's
switch this over and let me show you the
resource page quickly it probably
doesn't matter there's really nothing on
the resource page right now but I'll
show you anyway this is the resource
page on the old site basically there's
going to be two categories there's going
to be free resources and resources that
you have to pay for so the trick is we
need to come up with a card that is
going to be able to work for any data
type so these resources are going to end
up being
they could be links to text articles
okay
the menu links only work on a homepage
for right now since this will probably
get changed into react I don't really
see the point in building everything out
on every page the home page will be the
most complete and then you know that
this nav will be its own component that
we just get reused everywhere if we end
up not having time for that then you
know we'll just hurry up and copy and
paste it all over okay I don't know why
I just needed to click on that because
it still has all this basic stuff that I
copied to all the pages but ok looks
like some people oh man we got people
for both both fonts so this might be
tough might have a tie here and I'm just
gonna have to decide anyway um if we do
have a tie I don't
I don't know what on the video I'll use
both fonts on different pages and then
see what see what everybody likes that's
actually in charge of this department
and see what they think but basically we
need a card that's going to be able to
have to display video events from
YouTube text probably a link to a text
article images if we have a good image
to put with it or audio so it's going to
need like a title space for an image
space for a title probably a button
somewhere for a link and you can see
here's what you don't really put buttons
on cards Google puts you know we have
these little things so you don't you
don't put like a raised button on a card
in material design you can potentially
put I've seen it done where you put like
a little round action button somewhere
here on a card but I don't think we'll
need that I think that'll be necessary
so I'm thinking a card like this would
work we could have an optional image
that would maybe maybe be there maybe
not depending on whether one gets
uploaded this works it has a title yeah
we definitely need a short description
so people know what what it is and I
wonder if it would be worth it to
differentiate between cards somehow so
that people know right away whether this
is a paid resource or a free resource I
don't know what the best way would be
I'm thinking maybe I don't want to do a
completely different color but maybe
some sort of indication somewhere in the
card so that they can know at a glance
off to think about that maybe maybe an
icon from I guess the the marketer India
is thinking don't don't mark the paid
ones instead mark the free ones is free
and then people think hey this is
awesome is free but if they see the paid
thing that'll say all that things have
to pay for it so that's just me thinking
it's it's more positive to see
a label that says free than a label that
says you got to pay for this
I don't know that least that's what I a
small key icon will work okay a smokey
icon yeah that's that's cool actually
that's a good idea I should just look
through some icons and see fish an icon
that would work yeah that yeah a little
icon that would either maybe go at the
end of the title I was actually thinking
like you know kind of a little banner
right here but I think the key would be
easier to implement and would would look
nice great that's a great idea Thank You
Claude be for that idea all right I know
I've got to be run yeah I'm already over
on time so sorry about that I really
wanted to actually start to build this
card out but I got got sidetracked with
the fonts but I really do want your help
with deciding on the fonts because I can
spend forever looking at fonts and I
don't have that time right now
so thanks for watching thank you for
everybody being so awesome and the the
live chat and for interacting with me
and give me great ideas also is really
cool you guys kind of shout it out where
you were from I really like that that
was fun so I will be back with both
today's Friday so have a great weekend
I will live stream again on Monday
2:00 p.m. Eastern Time same time and I
maybe I'll save I don't have to work on
these cards I have a lot of other stuff
on the site that I could work on that
maybe isn't as exciting so probably on
Monday we can work on cards or if I find
something else that I think will be
interesting maybe we'll do that if you
have any topics that you really want me
to talk about let me know if it's
something that I'm going to do for this
site I can work it in ending yeah the
streamed ending I just stream for a half
an hour I don't I don't want to put
people through a super long video when
they go to watch the recording so I just
do half hour and also I I work a lot
slower when I have to narrate so if I
did this all day
way less work done that task manager I
was using is Trello I'll write that down
I'll put a link to it in the description
it's a free thing and it just lets me do
that actually github added something
similar to that so there's a feature on
github that does that as well I haven't
had time to use it yet I may switch to
at some point since I'm already using
github but for right now I'm used to
Trello so maybe I'll do a video on how I
manage my stuff a short video on at some
point if you guys if you guys want that
let me know it's really useful for solo
projects yeah sorry if I don't want this
chlamydia to go too long but you still
have questions I'll answer questions for
a couple more minutes see it's really
useful for solo projects yes Trello is
definitely useful for solo projects I'll
just show you quickly let me move this
off the screen like I said I'd like to
maybe do a video on this but just really
quickly to show you let me see if I can
make this bigger so you can see see the
font okay so I am I have it separated
into these lists so in Trello everything
is in a list and then cards so I have to
do ready for development in progress
testing and done every task is broken up
into these these lists in these cards
and so I can open it up I can put this
was the font task so I had the links to
those fonts I showed you in here you can
attach files and pictures and things if
I was working in a team I could assign a
task to somebody and they'd be able to
see it too and you could you know share
share your boards with with your team or
whoever you need to you can even share
it with your clients if you wanted them
to see the progress and have them you
know you could maybe put a screenshot in
or something and ask their opinion on
some something or have them add things
so it's really cool like I said even if
it's solo I use a pretty much solo all
the time in my department we have a
different project management system that
we use for the hold
apartment it's called Reich so I I
update tasks in there but no one else in
my department really cares or needs to
know all the little tasks so for that I
use this because it's just so fast I
also have these little numbers here
these are Pomodoro cycles so every 25
minutes I take a little break I have a
timer for that so I estimate how many
25-minute periods each of these tasks
will take so for right now to create the
cards for the resources which we were
just talking about I estimate that it
would take me three 25-minute periods
when I'm done I put let me show you when
that's done when I'm done at the end I
put how long it actually took so I went
to change the the mission page the about
page I assumed it it would take an
entire 25-minute period which is crazy I
I don't know why I said it would take
that long
it only took me half of that time
probably less than half of it so now I
can go back and see what I estimated you
know for this everything that's done
I've estimated 7.5 cycles and it's only
taken these six so it gives me a good
idea the more I do this the closer I get
so I'm able when somebody comes to me
like you know when my boss is the head
of my department comes in and says how
long is it going to be I can look at all
these to do's and how much I have left
and I said okay I have 39 7 it's I can
add this section up and I know about how
long it's going to take me before this
site is finished and that's really cool
there's some other cool charting stuff
you can do with this I don't really use
that a lot I imagine it would be more
helpful maybe if you're on a team but
this has really helped me to get my
estimates you know kind of on target
that was always the hardest thing for me
especially when I was like freelancing
uh you know when all my work was
freelance work it was really hard for me
to try to get a handle on you know how
how long is the project going to take
but this kind of forces me to estimate
every little thing and it's so much
easier to estimate a small
ask them to try to estimate a big task
so if you break it down estimating one
individually and then add it all up
you'll be so much closer to an accurate
an accurate number these kind of Kitty
arrows billing okay Club est you use
that to calculate your hours you're
building it to get better at estimating
yeah okay so pretty much everything um
all of the above
it does it does work well actually if
I'm calculating my hours this video is
going to be a little longer so I I guess
that's cool uh let's see do you think
it's possible fifteen-year-old to make
it and Web Design freelancing oh yeah I
think a fifteen-year-old could
definitely get get work a guy that I
used to work with a lot and he actually
got me I wasn't doing web design for a
lot I got into it a little bit uh when I
was in high school and done a little bit
of work and then I got away from it I
was actually teaching high school and
then I I quit teaching I did some stuff
from the stock market for a little bit
and then this guy was in this guy I went
to high school with was doing web design
stuff and he needed somebody to work
with so he got me back into it and he
was awesome also mentor and got me
introduced to a lot of good clients and
a lot of experience but he actually
started when he was really young he's a
couple years younger than me so he was
maybe 15 when he got started and he was
doing work for he has an uncle that has
a marketing company and he was going
work for his uncle as a teenager and
making making money so definitely just
try to be as professional as you can be
and you know it can't hurt that to ask
to propose things you know go run you
know just you go around to local places
I I don't recommend going on like kind
of the freelancing job boards to be
honest with you I haven't had much
success with that usually you don't
really make a lot of money people are
out bidding a lot so I kind of think
it's better to just um
go out and try to get contacts like
actual personal contacts either through
the internet by talking to people on
social media and forms and things or in
your local community that's I've gotten
the most clients in the best clients
from my connections my personal
connections and from referrals from
other clients I wasn't trying to ask
answer somebody else's question oh ok
somebody asked me about billing let me
show you real quick and this will
probably be the last thing I go over let
me show you how I track my projects so
I'm going to bring this over and this is
going to be small but that's ok because
you don't really need to see everything
but this this might seem crazy to you
but for for the University right now
every project that I've been working on
has its own tab in this spreadsheet at
the bottom here so I put the date the
number of hours that I've worked and
then a quick summary of what I've done
these summaries are basically the same
thing I put in my get commits and I have
a total at the bottom now for my job now
I don't get paid hourly so this is
basically just a way for me to keep
track that if I have to go in for a
performance review I can say you know
this this project brought in you know so
much money to the University if you
would have had a contract this out to
somebody it would have cost you so much
money you know if you were chart paying
an hourly so that's what this allows me
to do it's it's kind of nice to be able
to go in and tell my boss like you know
hey you've you saved a ton of money by
hiring me and having me do this work so
that's kind of I was already used to
doing this for my clients on the side so
I just kept doing it when I started
working here about two years ago and it
still comes in handy for me and when I
have clients I actually just used that
so I flipped over when I have clients
next to this number will actually be my
how much they they're paying me so if it
is an hourly job I'll just multiply this
number by what the hourly rate is and
right
year I'll have the the amount they owe
me usually it's some recurring clients
so each of these tabs would then be a
month so out of one spreadsheet per
client and then each month they would
get billed based on the the total number
here so I hope that's helpful I'm sure
there's probably better ways to do that
and I'm sure there are services that can
do that but we have to be extremely
organized yeah but it is great it's good
to be organized when you do all this
stuff I guess you don't have to be
depends on where you're working at but
it definitely helps it for sure helps if
you're on your own like it really helps
if specially if you need to keep track
of things for tax purposes uh then the
more documentation you have for
everything then it's better or if you
ever have to if a client doesn't want to
pay and starts asking you what did you
really do well you have very detailed
evidence of everything you've done on
that site at that point so I've run over
a lot longer than I anticipated and the
chats kind of slowing down so I'm going
to go but have a great weekend I'll be
back on Monday and thanks for watching